let's follow up on the situation in
North Carolina with this chant a
transgender bathroom bill HB 2 here's
the backstory some time ago the North
Carolina legislature passed a bill
called HB to that bill not only mandated
that individuals must use the bathroom
that corresponds with their birth
genitalia it also mandated that you
cannot have municipality level
non-discrimination ordinances with
regard to sexual orientation or gender
identity there was this backroom deal
made where Charlotte agreed to rescind
their non-discrimination ordinance and
in exchange Pat McCrory the Republican
governor agreed and the Republicans in
the North Carolina legislature agreed ok
Charlotte has rescinded what caused us
to pass HB 2 in the first place we will
get together and talk about repealing HB
to it was all expected to happen
smoothly even outgoing and disgraced
Republican Governor Pat McCrory one of
the most deplorable governors in the
country along with sam Brownback in
Kansas and Snyder in Michigan and and
quite a quite a long list of other
deplorable one of the top Republican
deplorable 'he's agreed we're going to
talk about this it's been a disaster for
the state businesses have been pulling
jobs out organizations have been pulling
events out of North Carolina Pat McCrory
losing his reelection campaign narrowly
and arguably at least in part because of
the uproar against HB 2 well the entire
repeal has absolutely and utterly and
embarrassingly imploded uh it's not
going to happen for at least six months
the General Assembly started a special
session yesterday they ended it after
nine hours with HB 2 still on the books
and Charlotte did its part on Monday
right they rescinded the law that was
the catalyst for HB to McCrory I'm not a
defender of Pat McCrory but the special
session was called just like Pat McCrory
said it would happen but instead of a
repeal the special session and
it would senator Phil Berger the
Republican leader in the house they're
putting in a measure to start a quote
six-month cooling-off period during
which nobody can make any changes to
ordinances of these of this type these
non-discrimination ordinances uh to two
ordinances relating to employment
discrimination and public accommodations
so this means that at minimum HB 2
remains in effect for six more months
and the General Assembly claims that
they're going to take these six months
to start working on what they call a
long-range solution to the issues
obviously it's unclear what their
definition of a solution even is but the
broader concern and Democrats in the
North Carolina legislature have voice
this concern these cooling off periods
could be extended indefinitely we're
gonna have a six-month cooling-off
period and in six months we're going to
have another six month cooling off
period now that may not happen for a
couple of reasons and I'll talk about
why number one there's the background
hope that when the New Democratic
governor Roy Cooper is sworn in that he
will end this nonsense and push for
statewide protections for sexual
orientation as well as gender identity
and end the retrograde insanity that's
the hope and we'll see if that happens
in the meantime though we have to
understand that the business impact the
financial impact of hb2 events pulling
out of North Carolina businesses
choosing to expand in other states
rather than in North Carolina that's
what has caused a lot of the uproar and
the discussion about whether hb2 needs
to go businesses need to continue
putting pressure on the state continue
to pull jobs out continue to pull events
keep doing it and you have to remember
there are still many Republicans in the
North Carolina legislature who
absolutely don't want this repealed they
are only even willing to consider it
because of the financial impact and
they're hearing from constituents when
businesses pull out their constituents
lose jobs and that is what is
influencing them and
you have to keep the pressure up this
from the beginning was this backroom
deal in exchange for repealing the
Charlotte non-discrimination ordinance
this isn't about Republicans seeing the
light about how much of a disaster this
bill is it is financial and we need to
keep the financial pressure up and
hopefully I be at this point who really
knows hopefully six months is it and
then hb2 will be gone will continue
following it into 2017 today's show is
brought to you by godaddy where you can
buy your own domain name build a website
or use any of Go Daddy's business tools
you can save thirty percent at try
godaddy.com slash david go daddy has
actually been the official host of the
david pakman show website for many many
many years the 24 7 customer support has
been a very good thing for us I've
called them at really odd times when we
we've had website issues and they are
always available they are the largest
domain registrar and whether you have a
new idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to godaddy they can do it all 13 million
customers try it and get thirty percent
off at try godaddy.com slash david